hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream
q a where every pet has a worse case
of attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder than the last
yep they sure do they sure do
but there will be no unforeseen
events this week with them none no
unforeseen we foresee the whole thing we
foresee everything looks like we have
become clairvoyant
yes all right let's do this uh
episode 75 q a all right here we are
here
are a couple first from last episode
have you looked into the research done
on the link between migration theory and
eating disorders if so what are your
thoughts
um yeah you wanna you i don't know
anything about this it was intriguing to
me i'd never heard anything about this
yeah i've never heard anything about it
either i will certainly say that i would
imagine
that there is a lot of interaction
between
light regime diet of
population of origin and uh current
eating patterns so yes it's going to be
a novelty problem then
likely where you've come from has a lot
to say about uh what has happened to you
so yeah i think it's interesting if
that's what it means
yeah yeah so i did not have a chance to
look this up
between now and then i just put it on me
like hey let's
let's see but anyway it's potentially
worth us thinking about
yep um
oh for god's sake
um
i'm gonna just read this question wow
that's just not
okay um we often speak
about the destructive effect of
pathogens introduced into native
populations of america by europeans
um but wouldn't there have been a
similar effect should we start over
um we could we could just start over no
okay
i think we're good i mean life happens
it comes at you fast sometimes in the
form of a hurricane cat
i did take him to the vet yep i'm hoping
anyway
he's not been eaten by coyotes for which
we are grateful
yes all right definitely that was
disturbing
okay next question you ready i am okay
we often speak about the destructive
effect of pathogens introduced into
native populations of america by
europeans
but wouldn't there have been a similar
effect on europeans from pathogens they
had not encountered before
is this a matter of historical emphasis
or narrative were european pathogens
more badass did it play out the way it
did due to population sizes what am i
missing
it's a great question addressed well in
guns germs and steel
and the idea there actually were some
pathogens that went the other direction
but far less pernicious and the basic
answer seems to be that because
of the european association with
domesticable creatures which is largely
a historical accident of most of the
domestic domesticable creatures on earth
having been residents of asia and asia
being a horizontally laid out continent
so that crops and animals could be moved
uh as populations migrated that because
there is no latitudinal gradient
precisely because of what we were
talking about in the last hour around
why
things are not invasible from the
tropics into the temperate zone usually
right so moving across longitude doesn't
pose
obvious climatic problems right as long
as you stay within a band of latitude
um your climate all else being equal
tends to be similar
right so in any case the basic point was
that europeans had
longer term um experience
with association with these domesticable
creatures with whom
they exchanged pathogens and so european
immunity was higher
there are very few uh domesticated
large domesticated creatures in the new
world as a matter of fact i think
only llamas are
um are in that category i believe that's
right and so
in any case the basic point little
things like guinea pigs right
yeah little things yes but uh big things
no and
the association with those things is
what caused european immunity to be what
it was and caused the
number of pathogens that therefore
circulated amongst europeans and the
intensity of those
illnesses when people in the new world
encountered them
to be much greater yep and there was a
certain amount of nefarious
behavior as well um like spreading of
sharing of blankets that had
um that had germ in them
yes and no this is apparently a fact
with some historical backing and
also largely apocryphal not as
widespread as some would have us believe
but it did happen
it appears that it did happen
but i would point out this is well
earlier than the germ theory of disease
and so what was understood about
what was being distributed and what's
effect would be is
less clear but yes can we get us both on
the screen
should we pause and resume or should we
just keep going
okay okay um yeah let's just continue
okay
here we are guys um
but yeah it as as i had remembered as
you just uh
explained uh it's it's well
it's well explored in guns germs and
steel man we have cat madness here today
what are you doing man
they are going stir crazy as a result of
the lack of
ability to go outside yeah and i think
as a result they ate their treats too
fast and
made themselves a little sick one of
them okay next question
this one is from the discord this week
the market is a powerful and important
force and so is the news
as of late the two don't appear to be
mixing well however
government-controlled news seems even
more suspect
what is the future of the news and
information gathering in this post-truth
era
i don't think anybody knows but i would
just point out that i think we were
asking for
predictions yeah what we what we had in
the
prior era was more or less an agreement
on a single
shared narrative and i think market
forces have now
driven that uh the dissolving
of the shared narrative and so now we
have multiple incompatible narratives
which is obviously hugely
self-destructive
the shared narrative wasn't inherently
true in the past though it often was
because in general there was
um there was a reason for people to want
an understanding of what was taking
place rather than to want
an understanding or want a narrative
that simply placed them at advantage
but at some level we're going to need to
have a
mechanism for figuring out what is
approximately true and um
a recognition that one's perspective is
always
uh inherent in there and the pretense of
objectivity
is just that a pretense so acknowledging
one's biases is much better
than pretending they don't exist and you
know there are
efforts uh along these lines so daniel
schmoktenberger is
working on a project in which we are
consulting which aims to do this but i
think we don't really know because
we uh we there's too much at stake and
no mechanism for
preventing the perversion
of information uh or
the shutting down of those who would
attempt to generate something that would
falsify
the important narratives yeah
that's that's good it's not good
no it's not good i approve that answer
okay
okay um sorry i'm a bit thrown by the
chaos here
breathe yes that's important just to
even do it regularly
thank you it's these regular reminders
from you that keep me going
yes well i'm glad to hear that i i feel
good
that i play some vital role oh so many
so many all right it's getting better
most of my romantic releases this is the
first question that we're reading from
this last hour
uh most of my romantic relationships
have only lasted about four months
i've read that a crush lasts four months
i've had several relationships go south
around that time
what is happening to us biologically
after four months and can you explain
why in the evolutionary context
i would say before you start to riff
that it that the question hinges on that
that four-month thing being something
that's real and i
i don't know it to be i've never read
that and i have so i haven't i haven't
seen that in literature
it is certainly possible that there's
something of a you know of a particular
length of time after which the sort of
uh you know the lust chemicals give way
to the love chemicals as it were right
it's the at the
mechanistic but um not using technical
terms level of
analysis but i don't know that to be
true i wouldn't say it's
uh lust versus love yeah it's not quite
right but
um there's an infatuation thing and
there's a love thing
and infatuation sometimes gives way to
love but not always
and the problem is that um
what do you think though about the idea
that there is like a reliable
time period i would suspect that it
might be reliable within
individuals and somewhat much more
variable between individuals there's
probably
variable variability between individuals
variability between populations
and variability even between
relationships
but what i would say is understanding
what those states
are is really important right and i
would argue
that love is an honest state
that the purpose of it is to cause a
an individual to grant symmetrical
status to someone else or something else
right to put somebody else
on a par with the way you view the
importance of self
and that infatuation is actually almost
the opposite of this
that in fact infatuation its function
is deceptive right so when somebody
is in that state they
are in that state in order to deceive
the person on the other end
of that state into thinking they are
better than they are in other words
imagine that under normal circumstances
you can be
x amount good to a partner right but you
really want that partner because it's
the right person for you or some part of
you thinks that it is
right and so the idea is well how are
you going to lock down a relationship
with that person well you're going to
convince them
that you're able to be better to them
than you actually are
and it's like the mental acrobatics
version of not wearing sweatpants
you're just you're putting on your best
show right it's it's marketing it's it's
it's the pr
stage early stage of the relationship
it's almost beyond it's an
unsustainably good show and so
the basic point is that is a built-in
um yeah there's a lot of cat stuff going
on
that is a built-in deceptive program
that uh because two people often end up
in that state
together right if you discover that
you're you know
crushing on somebody who isn't
interested then the point is investing
and showing them
a better than best self is uh pointless
right so you get over it if the other
person reciprocates and you're both
showing each other an unsustainable
level of goodness
then the question is well do you
discover in this process that the person
is worth hanging on to even though they
can't deliver on
what they seem to be able to deliver on
and
anyway with respect to your
relationships
a no idea what fraction of the issue
is you know you or who you
settle upon or the modern context
in which these things unfold which may
be setting you up for failure
having nothing to do with either of you
the context could include uh
unusually high standards that are
actually unmutable by virtue of
you know everything from photoshopping
to porn to expectations of social media
right and so one thing maybe the
most useful thing to say
is we are not well served by
a set of
narratives i think largely driven by the
market
that conflates um
that infatuated state with love itself
oh that infatuated state is true love
[ __ ] no it isn't right true love is
what happens if
the relationship has the characteristics
necessary to
persist indefinitely right that initial
state may
feel good but it's fake and so
by selling people on the idea
do you really mean fake
i'm trying not to give it more credit
than it deserves
and the basic point is true love
relationships
start this way right but then they have
this other characteristic
lots of relationships the majority of
relations which
you know i don't know you could
analogize it to the frosting or you know
like
a number of things like it doesn't
doesn't make it fake it's just not the
same as
like calling both things you know if you
do end up in a long-term relationship in
which you are in love and therefore
seeing i was falling in love and that's
what that was they're really two very
different things
using the same word to describe the same
those two things is well
misleading let's say i am not sure how
to put what i'm saying
but the fact that that initial state
either gives way to true love or doesn't
and that from within that state
you can't tell right means that it is
not
you know the
just keep talking see this is the thing
the honest
relationship that ultimately emerges has
to endure
you know unruly cats and everything all
right
um there's nothing for him there
but the point that i was uh trying to
make
is that the important question
the one with a lot of meaning to it yes
is whether or not there is a
relationship there that has the
characteristics
of permanence right and the fact that
this other state
a very frequently happens without giving
way to a relationship that has that
state to me
means that it is uninformative all it
says is the possibility of that other
thing
existing there is real but you know
nothing about whether it is
so i do think it's fake and the idea
that um because it is intense and
because
the long-term relationship is not as
intense not remotely as intense
that the idea that literature and
everything else comes to
focus on that state as if it is
insightful
when it is in fact the opposite is it
makes for a harder story
that's what it is it makes for
unfortunately it makes for a
saleable story um now
i will say we have yeah better
yeah better is maybe exactly the wrong
choice of words so we've been watching
uh
with our kids we've been watching uh the
hbo miniseries the pacific
and in part we were driven to watch it
because we had watched a bunch of other
world war two stuff that focused on the
european theater
including band of brothers which
immediately was is the same creative
team
right and i must say one of the things
that's very
jarring i find about the pacific is
this portrayal of actual love and how it
starts that is very resonant
but does not look like a modern story
and my sense is that this has been lost
because the market has
overwritten the right story of how this
works
with a phony [ __ ] story that
misleads people into thinking they know
what they're looking for when really
they don't know anything of the kind
um so anyway i would say be careful
about
accepting what the market wants to tell
you you're looking for
because the market doesn't know [ __ ]
other than how to con you into spending
money on things that
probably aren't in your interest and you
know
love is complex um
definitely worthwhile but uh it doesn't
it doesn't sell as much stuff yeah
all right next question the cdc says
that antibody testing is not recommended
to assess for immunity to sars cov2
following coped 19 vaccination can you
explain why that would be
stay wonderful well so again i don't
yeah go on if it's even true
right so i was going to say again i
don't the the the claim
that starts it is one that we have not
assessed um that the cdc
says right the antibody testing is not
recommended to assess for immunity to
sars
following vaccination so there are two
things that could be true okay
that we don't know one is that the cdc
said this which maybe they did
um uh the other is if the cdc said it
is it um
meaningful biologically right right
if it is if the cdc said it and it is
meaningful biologically
there's a way it could be true which is
that the production
of antibodies is so reliable
from the vaccines or the production the
inducing of immunity is so reliable that
you don't need antibody testing
because it's confirmatory of something
that is so close to 100 percent that you
just don't need to know no i don't buy
that but
that's that but it's possible okay so
anyway that could be what the claim is
um but we don't know
uh can you imagine though can you
imagine any other
if this is if it is true that the cdc
has said this
can you imagine any other way that
biologically it would make sense
yeah one other what which is that uh and
it's a
it's related but um it could be that the
immunity which matters
is t cell not b cell and therefore
the b cell thereby the antibody
titer is uh too noisy
to be useful and that the information
that you have gotten the vaccination
is therefore a more reliable indicator
than
than the uh the test would be yeah i
actually i
find that a bit more compelling that the
the data would be
too noisy to interpret as opposed to
so guaranteed to be already what we know
that we don't needn't even bother
yeah which strikes me as a you know
deeply anti-scientific reason whereas
it's just going to be too noisy we won't
be able to make we won't be able to
detect pattern
we won't be able to make to know
anything on the basis of that therefore
it's pointless to do um if so
yeah that that strikes me as
not irresponsible of them if they said
it if that is the reason why
well what you would want to know is that
the work was done properly to tell you
what the implications were and you would
also want to recognize
that let's say
antibody titer is too
noisy two months after injection
to be informative you would still want
to know
what things looked like six months a
year
three years six years totally down the
road and so at some level i have the
sense of
there's way too much pretense that we
know how this works and therefore
understand its implications and are
therefore
making policy and recommendations on the
basis of it that
can't possibly be right but yeah yeah
you could imagine a data set that would
give you reason to say such things
next question heather said that abigail
schreier wanted her book to be longer
i noticed that her book leaves out the
medical industrial billionaire
philanthropy angle as a reason for the
craze
did she want this in the book i don't
know the answer to that
um and i could ask her
but i i don't i just don't know because
i um
i read the version i read one longer
chapter
in which um that was twice as long as
the chapter
um that i showed up in briefly
from my from her interview with me um
and i can speak to i could speak to what
was
pulled from that but i otherwise read
only the book as it is then published
um we are breastfeeding a seven week old
and may get the j j vaccine next week
are there any potential hazards we
should consider any benefit to waiting
one to two months before deciding on the
j
j one given that we are isolating and
low risk
um so i'll just say just this is gonna
sound snarky but this is just a
long-standing
um slight linguistic irritation of mine
that um
except in extraordinarily rare
situations people don't collectively
breastfeed their baby
um and this started to become a thing
like in the 90s i think you know we're
pregnant no
you're not she's pregnant um we're
breastfeeding nope
she's breastfeeding well in this one
case
oh i see the look on your face but i'm
right on this one so
in this case there's a strong chance
that uh they are breast pumping which
has its own set of hazards associated
with it but
it what would the term be if a couple
is using breast milk but both of them
are doing the feeding
yeah i think i would still say you know
bottle feeding from breast milk or
something just because breastfeeding is
um the act the the behavioral
interaction as well but
you know it's it's a it's a minor thing
yeah and this question
is terrific and um and certainly the
person asking it doesn't deserve any i'm
not
angry or upset just like i'll bet only
one of you is breastfeeding
um any potential hazards uh to getting a
j j vaccine while breastfeeding a
practically a neonate i'm seven weeks
isn't neonate but really really quite
young still
any benefit to waiting one to two months
um
given that you're isolating in low risk
i think so
i i think there's a benefit to to just
letting that kid get as much life behind
him or her as possible before before
exposing them
i can't remember actually what the
schedule of vaccines
for babies is it's been a long time
since ours were tiny but
um i don't think they vaccinate right
away do they don't they wait maybe six
weeks is actually the first vaccination
date and then mostly i don't remember
and um
so you know we the expectations that
this um the effects of any vaccine that
mom gets can be passed through breast
milk and
i don't know for sure that's true here
but that's the expectation and
so especially if for instance the
regular vaccination schedule for baby
doesn't start until six months
um i would be real shy about um mom
who is breastfeeding getting any
vaccination not
not just one that happens to be brand
new with a
new technology um well the baby is still
so young
yeah and that's just that's just caution
it's not based on data we don't have the
data
i i agree um there is some evidence of
immunity
to sars kobe 2 being passed in breast
milk whether that could carry over from
a vaccine
and whether it even matters in this case
since kids seem to be
immune to it in the first place or very
close to immune to it
but you know the the basic answer is
you're dealing with a novel intervention
in a complex system
you don't know what could be downstream
of that so
caution and therefore delaying things is
sensible and what you have to put that
up against is something like
the risk of contracting of the parent
contracting sars
kovi ii right um in the interim
i would say the non-breastfeeding parent
should go ahead with the schedule you
know if it were if it were us
and we were scheduled and i had a seven
week old
baby at the breast um and we had decided
that now is the time
to get the j j vaccine um i would i
think that i would push for you to go
ahead and get it and me to wait as long
as we felt
safe and because that would help protect
us collectively
yes the important thing though is if the
decision was that it made sense to get
it
right if we had come to the conclusion
if we had come to that conclusion and so
anyway we are not eligible yet so we
have not come to any definitive
conclusion but i would say you and i
both have
trepidations about all of these uh novel
at various different level vaccines
um and are at comparatively low risk
based on how much we're interacting with
other people
so uh it it unfortunately is a very
personal
decision but yes uh with a with a child
breastfeeding
um i would say there is extra extra risk
and uh reason for caution especially if
you're in a safe situation
yep can you
two-part question can you increase mouse
or any animal lifespan by selecting for
long-lived mice i.e breeding mice in a
lab and continually removing descendants
of shorter-loved mice
like the bottom half from the breeding
group alternatively
can you increase mouse lifespan by
gradually increasing the age in which
they are allowed to reproduce
generation over generation selecting for
those that can reproduce at every older
ages
i feel like this is in your wheelhouse
yes um yeah 100 you can
um the second one you can
so my my understanding is that both of
these mechanisms will work so i was just
clarifying you were
you're saying both of these um removing
descendants of surety lived mice from
the breeding group
and um increasing the age at which
they're allowed to reproduce
yes and i will point out there is one
very tantalizing
result i'm not sure how well it stood up
but
back when i was doing my telomere work
there was one result that suggested
that telomere length which is the
regulator of
tissue repair and therefore the capacity
to live a longer life
um telomere length goes up in
male in the sperm produced by males
with the age of the father so that is to
say that across the reproductive
lifespan of an individual male
the later in the lifespan that the
sperm is produced the longer telomeres
and therefore
uh greater longevity um all else being
equal
the offspring are predisposed to and so
what that suggests
that's fascinating because like that
runs counter to some of the
some of the now known um costs of
um babies across mammals born to older
fathers
right but um
[Music]
the imagine the following thing imagine
that you've got a species
in which there is dispersal to new
habitats and that the
extrinsic risk to an individual varies a
lot between habitats
so let's suppose you came from a habitat
in which the extrinsic risks were very
very high
and therefore nobody tended to live a
very long time and therefore it made
sense
um to forego the potential for longevity
in order to resist cancer at younger
ages
um but then you moved into some place
where there were
a lack of predators or whatever and so
the question is do you want to wait for
evolution to
tinker telomere length or do you want to
build in
a mechanism that detects that males are
living longer and
ramps up the increase in telomere length
by basically saying well
if the offspring was produced late then
it should have longer telomeres because
that means living
late is possible right so anyway it's a
built-in mechanism that could
effectively detect a change in
circumstance
and rapidly change a population even
to uh greater longevity capacity so
anyway don't know whether that result
has stood up but it was certainly
tantalizing very good
i have failed for my first university
lost two jobs and spent thousands on
lost items
i suffer from debilitating shame and
anxiety attacks when i have to do a dull
and menial task
and so i have been diagnosed with adhd i
also tested with an iq of 143
and i'd love to learn i want to get a
phd but i've been told that it's
probably not the best idea for me
how is this fair why is my intellect
less than just because my brain works
differently
yeah i mean i feel like it's all built
into that question um
but yeah you know it's not fair yeah
it's not fair and it's not
probably not the best idea for you well
i'm not sure that getting a phd in any
modern university is the best idea for
anyone
but that's not because um you're broken
that's because it's broken yep yeah yeah
um
yeah i mean that and it's just the
the tweet that i showed about this new
drug
for you know adhd you know you know
broken children like i
i said that hoping that everyone would
read it knowing that i was
joking that you know we we have we can
talk internally about the ways in which
we are broken and
and um and that can be a useful way of
thinking about things and you know some
of the trade-offs don't seem as you know
as wonderful you know we might if we
could go back you know change some of
the trade-offs that we are now stuck
with
but um the pathologizing of all variants
is a modern thing that is causing people
to
feel things like shame and embarrassment
and
to not pursue things that they would be
extraordinarily well suited for
if you love to learn and you're mentally
gifted of course a phd in some field in
which you are passionate should be a
great choice for you
um again i'm not sure that i'm not sure
that the flaming hoops that you're
expected to jump through under the best
of conditions in the modern university
um will you know they might well be
nearly impossible for you and add to
those the now
now even more great has copes hoops
around uh diversity equity and inclusion
and it may not be worth your while but
not because of you
yeah i would also say there's really
very little that you
need unless you're talking about a very
technical field
there's very little you need a phd
program in order to learn
it would be lovely if these programs
were excellent
for fostering uh high quality thought
but
they're getting worse and worse and and
access to information has never been
better so if the point is love of
learning
rather than acquiring a credential don't
let the fact that a phd program might
not be the right place for you to
dissuade you from
figuring out how to learn the material
that fascinates you
it's also possible just one more thing
before we move
topics i used to stay up on this ish
when we were professors because you know
part of
part of what i saw my job as was to
advise people who came to me and said
i'm interested in graduate school and so
i was thinking a lot about
the already by then decaying
academic system within the us and um
was able at least for a while to uh
to feel good about recommending some
programs in europe
and the uk and australia and i don't
know at this point
um you know how how captured
all the other offshore offshore from the
perspective of the us
um programs are i think canada is just
as bad as the us
but australia europe uh uk
might have some some pockets um that
look a little different but i don't know
yep that's a good point
and then you get to live somewhere else
and experience different cultural
expectations and all of that and that in
itself is
an education i worked in a hospital next
question
i worked in a hospital for years with a
huge psych service there i saw drugs
make zombies out of people
just good to hear rational thoughts
thank you thank you
love the book dart recommendation you
read my mind on what i needed
good also i think every movement could
benefit from a good anthem to help
convey its message
if the unity movement doesn't have one
yet may i suggest a better bridge by
thrice
do you know the song i don't okay well
you're gonna look into it all right
you're gonna listen to that song
and i'm 45 all right oops hold on i just
grade that out rather than making it
bright it's the exact opposite of what i
was trying to do there we go
we tend to think of humans as naturally
diurnal however for as long as i can
remember i've always had an easier time
staying awake all night than arising
before noon even as a child
are some people naturally nocturnal i
saw this question and i forgot to grab
the book
that i wanted to show that i've
mentioned on screen before it's called
when i think it's called when um
and i can't remember anything more about
it um except that he basically the
author
he calls it rather than a a how-to guide
a when two guide and basically talks
about the diversity um
in timing of of people mostly he's
talking about weird
cultures you know western educated
industrialized rich democratic
but also i think does some mythological
stuff and like sure of course there will
be variability in terms of
you know larks versus night owls i think
is the
usual bird analogy that is used wow um
so we suggested in a recent live stream
that it's possible that older people
take on a uh
staying up and watching over
a population role so that would suggest
some
reason for variability but not between
people yeah that's a change over
lifespan
right i would just say the important
thing to say about
are some people nocturnal
is no not ancestrally and we know that
they're not
nocturnal ancestrally because their eyes
aren't built for it so to the extent
that anything you would do
um would require you to be able to see
this is really only
novelly possible as a result of electric
lights
yeah we don't have that to penum lucidum
that coyotes and cats and other
nocturnal mammals do
that's how you can really see you can
tell is a species
historically nocturnal or not that said
modernity i went through a stage in
which i was
much more productive late at night
than any other time and the basic reason
was because i was
easily distracted by interesting stuff
going on in the world
and when we were limited to interacting
with people who were local when the
world was asleep
it meant there was nothing to do did you
also stand up sometimes when you were
expected to be sitting
uh sometimes i would find myself one
minute in a chair
the very next minute not in a chair i
would stand up
and uh whether this was adhd
or some as yet undiagnosed
non-chair sitting kind of disorder i
don't know
i feel like i should have been warned
you probably should have been yeah but
anyway my point is
this has changed for me because there's
no longer a period when the world is
asleep
because we now you could just say it
because the entire world has gotten so
boring
nothing is distracting to you anymore no
it's quite the opposite
the problem is because we're interacting
with people from all over the globe
there is no period in which if you stay
up late enough suddenly you can get work
done because there's nobody to talk to
right so anyway that ship has sailed but
my point is it was a
matter of novelty um that
people were up to some point it was a
matter of convention that people locally
would go to sleep
leaving you free to work yeah that's now
evaporated as a result of the way the
internet functions
um but none of this is ancestral
ancestrally
barring the kinds of considerations
about older people uh watching out for
danger when others are asleep
well well no i so not nocturnal
versus diurnal but um you know this book
and i found the name of it when
the scientific secrets of perfect timing
by daniel pink published
in 2018 um
made for me a very compelling argument
for natural variation
and you know you tend to be most active
and alert and able to do sort of
creative work
in the early morning as opposed to you
know midday as opposed to
evening before before bed so it's not a
diurnal nocturnal question
um but a a question of variability
within
the optimal period of time for which
humans are adapted
which daylight period which then
contracts and expands
weirdly for those of us uh living in
the temperate zones um so that raises
questions too
right but um well well anyway i
think we've answered it which is yes
you're built to be awake when it's light
um as for within that there might be
variation
there probably is um
congratulations on 75 episodes you've
covered it all from testicular tanning
to sexy bees
that does seem like a that's a narrow
narrow slice
uh um unless the where the bees doing
the testicular tanning they don't have
external genetics yeah
um and actually the sexy bees i don't
remember what the bees thing was but
it's probably all females
i can't remember sexy bees i don't
remember the bees okay um was that us
i'm sure it was shout out to ekko and
the rest of the gang for all the cool
questions brett
paraphrasing paraphrasing has said that
he believes individual consciousness to
be an illusion
an artifact of shared consciousness this
sounds very buddhist
hindu taoist cool why
elaborate please not an illusion a
secondary an epiphenomenon right so
individual consciousness definitely
exists you can check on your own
individual consciousness and in fact you
have better evidence for your own
individual consciousness than you have
for anybody else's consciousness or
certainly for a collective consciousness
however it's very hard to explain
individual consciousness
in evolutionary terms as the initial
driving
force because
what advantage does subjective
experience have it has tons of costs
right including misperceiving things uh
and just the energetic expense of
creating
an internal world that mirrors the
outside world why not just be wired to
do
right that is not the case with respect
to exchanging ideas
right when you exchange ideas with
others
there is a very definite reason that to
have a subjective experience so that you
can
take what you think is going on and what
you believe somebody else thinks is
going on
and integrate them in order that you
know so the conversation really does
exist
um what's the term for it uh
inter-subjectively
so anyway if you imagine that there
being
some place where
the content of a conversation is modeled
then it's very easy to understand why
individual consciousness evolves on top
of that because once you have the
ability to converse with somebody else
and exchange
abstract ideas and make progress you
also then have the
prerequisite to have a dialogue with
yourself and debate between two
possibilities
so if uh consciousness existing between
individuals evolves
for the obvious reason that it is useful
then individual consciousness has a
reason to exist but it's hard to
understand how you would get to
individual consciousness first
that's the reasoning very good
where did the idea we can't tell people
the truth because they won't know what
to do with it come from
is it true you guys are dope thank you
very much for your efforts
um yeah i have wondered this i don't
know where it came from i think it feels
it feels like a mechanism of social
control rather than anything that anyone
actually ever thought was true
but maybe i'm underestimating the
dimness of people who make such
pronouncements
no i think it's purely a rationalization
designed to excuse not telling people
what the [ __ ] is going on because it's
in your interest not to tell them
yeah um and so i am i am one who
believes it is you know
that is not to say that you can't
architect a scenario
there are situations when you know
national security
uh means that you can't tell the
populace what is going on
yeah but there are probably
circumstances in which the likelihood of
people surviving something
goes up if you uh
tell white lies about what they're up
against blah blah blah you could imagine
it in a small context
it's very hard to imagine um
it being anything other than an excuse
when the question is what
circumstance is the nation in and what
what is its implication
for us um although you know i guess i
guess you could come up with something
where
a nation had a low chance of surviving a
military encounter
and the chance went up if people
didn't realize how dire was you could
imagine it but
in my lifetime i've watched this thing
abused so many times god
um and then it's abused at all scales
this thing is fractal like
you see this you see this in classrooms
all the time you see so many
you know we've we've got more experience
seeing other college-level faculty but i
assume it also happens in k-12
classrooms where
i just lie to students because it's
easier for the faculty in the moment
yeah about you know
about what's true about what's expected
about all sorts of things like
boy and you're supposed to be educating
them right yeah yeah
yeah not lying to students is amazing
what it does
for your ability to be productive with
them
yeah and like i've had good
relationships and
yeah it's pretty easy to
don't lie every time i try to talk about
the loudly hypothesis with my peers i'm
shut down and berated
people seem to have total apathy towards
the origin of covid why
is this any advice this is totally
related to the last question
different person um but uh but
you know i don't i i think we've all
been informed
people who get their news from
left-leaning publications have been
informed that apathy is the only at some
level the only patriotic response
that to to to be thinking about it
is frankly now to be a cyanophobe uh
to you know you're racist you're
secretly gonna you know hoping that
trump is in office like i don't even
know what exactly it is but
there's just a whole lot of societal
level control behind
this thing that comes out looking like
apathy yes
you've been predisposed to believe that
if you question this thing that bad
stuff will happen to you so people are
rationalizing not doing it
there's also though a problem where
because people don't understand
evolution or complex systems i hear all
the time
well probably it makes no difference
where it came from in terms of what we
will do about it
but it would be good to know or why do
we need to know
we wouldn't change anything about how
we'd uh approach it which is absolutely
and then your motives are suspect why do
you care so much
right but this is absolutely not true
right to the extent that we are talking
about something that may have been
modified
in a lab it has every implication or at
least potentially has every implication
for what we would do and what we would
predict and therefore how we might
modify our behavior and basically when
somebody tells you well it doesn't make
any difference
they're telling you they don't
understand how evolution works because
we're really asking you know
where did it come from well if it came
from a lab that was trying to make it
more transmissible between humans
in order to study its effect
then that's a whole set of information
about what the thing is and
how it behaves of course it's going to
have implications so
um you know i think the answer is sorry
you just
failed the logic part of the test yeah
um you know try again yeah okay one more
question then we'll move to the next
hour's questions are fingernails
are fingernails an evolution of claws or
an unrelated adaptation
thanks love the podcast yes
yeah they are um what's called
homologous with claws
um and yeah i mean we could go on and on
and on but
yeah i've always wondered whether
they've been modified in order to
increase
the acuity of the fingertips well so
so fingernails is a
i believe it's a primate synapomorphy it
might be simian so synapomorphy means a
shared derived character that is new to
that group and new at the
new at the level of that group and
although the thing
might show up in some distantly related
group that would be a
co-evolution and so for instance you
could talk about
you know wings in birds are probably a
snap morphe for birds but wings and
ducks are not a snap morphe all ducks
have wings
but the wingedness of ducks is not new
with ducks you have to go back to the
most recent common ancestor of all birds
before you find the origin of wings
similarly
i believe that nails if memory serves
um are a it's either a primate
synapomorphy or it's a slightly smaller
group within primates
and um the actually i think i think
and it's you know it's not a um discrete
character it's not like claws versus
nail so i believe that things like
lemurs
and uh like bush babies and even
tarsiers which
lives in this weird weird space in the
primate philogeny
um have a sort of a cl claw like thing
and as soon as you get
um nails you also get finger pads and
toe pads
and you get like so you get fingerprints
you get toe prints and you get more
dexterity
yeah yeah well that's more or less what
i'm thinking yeah
to increase your uh neurological
feedback yeah fingers
yeah um i will point out though as long
as we're here
um clause continue
in pinnipeds that is seals
and sea lions on their flippers so if
you
look at the flipper of a sea lion you
will see that it has
the claws on the on the flipper itself
even though the fingers have been lost
yeah um anyway so it's kind of cool
very cool um
you remind me actually so i didn't we
didn't end up talking about it today and
we probably won't
later but even if we do i came across
just some ridiculous big formal document
from
i don't think european agency on sex and
gender and how we need to be thinking a
lot more about
how sex gender plays out in medicine and
all of this and into the middle of this
they're like
and in sea turtles the role of gender is
important because
temperature sex determination yeah
because because
um suddenly if this is a real concern
that there is a
because of climate change a lot a lot
more turtles
are coming out female than male because
sex is actually determined by the
temperature at which they develop as
opposed to by chromosomes
which has zero to do with gender it's
all about sex
and also they put that into a document
that's also about how
um ai can't recognize trans people as
well as
people who identify as the sex that they
were born to sfc turtles have anything
to do with that
at all people are just trying to throw
everything together
and confuse everyone such that they just
shut up already yeah hence the apathy
yeah um okay we're gonna go to
the this hour's questions which will be
somewhere
have you guys seen it's awfully tiny
have you guys seen
the not cloning your grandpa clip from
rick and morty
no i have not either okay that's the
answer to that
uh is this is from echo is there a
purpose to flowers and plants
smelling stronger during and after rain
even though pollinating insects can't
fly
during the rain presumably also do
animals hunt more after rain when cents
are magnified
love you both be well yeah it's a good
question about whether
the plant is investing something in
smelling after a rain i can see a lot of
arguments for one
if you if an insect can't fly during the
rain
and it normally flies to get to the
plants that would be pollinating then
there would at least in circumstances
where it has rained a lot
be an incentive to
[Music]
um to compete for pollinators
at that moment so you might imagine an
arms race between plants where they put
out more smell chemicals so the
prediction of that hypothesis would be
that there's actually
measurable difference in investment and
that the plants are choosing to invest
after the rain
rather than the rain and the humidity
that is therefore
around increase the degree to which the
plants smell without them changing
anything about what they're doing
i like it and at a um approximate level
it could well be that the types of
odorants that plants use
are water limiting and so um they don't
have to be
as um as parsimonious with them
um when water is abundant yep that's
true
i don't i don't know if that's true i
like it it's also if if the odor
if the production of odorants is water
limited normally then okay let's do this
also possible that if it is true that
insects cannot fly in the rain and
certainly many of them will not
then the
flowers will presumably delay maturation
until the rain has stopped which might
result in just there being more flowers
and therefore more surface area
yeah or like a slowing of development
and then acceleration development such
that you just like
put put out more odorant per unit time
because you're now
you're concentrating that over a smaller
array of time
and the um the way to test all of these
things
is to use things that are pollinated by
different critters
as controls
so you know if hummingbirds for example
fly during a rain that is
sufficiently light whereas insects don't
because
that same amount of rain disrupts them
then you would expect
the hummingbird flowers to be less
affected so things like that yeah good
hummingbird flowers don't smell but i
just do not mean to imply that one of
the things that diagnoses hummingbird
yeah pollinated flowers is that they
don't smell in general um bird
pollinated
bird pollinated flowers and bird
dispersed fruits both will have far
less smell than mammal dispersed fruits
there's not much mammal
pollinated that i can think of oh well
bad bad stuff of course yeah
um or insect both insects and mammals
have much more developed sense of smell
than birds do yes interestingly bat
i forgot about bats there for a moment
that's bad
bat so you can diagnose what pollinates
of something based on things like the
intersection of the color
and the smell so a beautiful red flower
that has no smell tends to be
hummingbird
a red or yellow flower that has an
intense smell tends to be
insect a white flower especially if it
smells a little bit like
a rotting pumpkin tends to be bat um
so anyway it's it's interesting but you
can walking through the forest with a
little bit of knowledge you can
almost always figure out what is
supposed to pollinate or what
yeah there's also the timing of course
you get like you know you had some of
these crepuscular blooming flowers
that are hawk moth pollinated for
instance totally yeah um
that ones do that too i remember yes
photographic
again i forgot about the bats yeah again
you forgot about the they're beginning
to take it personally as am i i know
not even four months in uh this person
asks says
states okay not even four months in and
biden is putting kids in cages
banning guns by fiat expanding the court
bribing illegals ending abraham accords
surrendering to china and more
anyone regret their vote yet you both
are exempted
um there's two things on that list so
this again is someone writing in and i
don't know
i don't know anything about the
expanding the court i know there's a lot
of talk about it before the election
um is that is that happening i don't
know i don't know anything about it
um but yeah there's a few things on this
list that i'm not aware of but um
yeah you know the kids in cages thing
it's just it makes it so clear how much
political theater we're engaged in
because um as was abundantly clear to
anyone paying attention during the trump
administration no matter how much you
hated the man
um this was not new with him yeah and
presumably little has changed
um since you know the current
president's uh
president who you know he served under
was in office
you know i i think that obama trump and
biden have all basically kept the same
policies
um in place and it's it's producing a
tremendous amount of
of misery and um somehow we see about it
only when
um we're trying to win political um
scores yep now there's an awful awful
lot that was just very easy
to uh to predict about what was coming
um
right and here we are here we are
shouldn't surprise no matter how you
voted this shouldn't surprise anybody
right check out jordan's response to red
skull he has merchandised it with a
comedic and artistic flair with all
proceeds going to charity
classy i don't know about that
um i had a lizard interrupt your live
stream as i was doing yard work pacific
northwest northeast of seattle
can i keep him how do i release him we
already have one herp
i'll send the moderator a couple of
pictures yeah what uh what lizard was
was this a
scalabrus fence lizard blue belly or
northeast of seattle
yeah it's going to be shiny
kobe and uda send pictures yes
i love lizards
um and maybe yeah send pictures and
maybe we'll return to this
next time start with lizards can we do
an all lizard
podcast maybe we just do all all lizard
podcasts
but they'll be very rabid in a good way
okay is there a theory of homosexuality
in evolutionary psychology
one source claims it's a strategy for
tricking women into sex
which seems to ring um
no i don't think that's a very good
explanation um yeah i got one i haven't
i haven't unveiled it yet it's coming
though wait wait oh wait which doesn't
next question which is not ring true i
mean not a strategy for meeting women
okay
so the person asking the question is not
confused by that hypothesis which is
a stupid hypothesis yeah that just
doesn't fit yeah
so you're not going to share what what
you think here no it
deserves a proper venue um so anyway
it's it's coming but it's not uh
this isn't the one yeah okay um where
are we at zach
hour and something yet okay so we're
gonna try to get to
i don't know five eight more of these
did you get a chance to watch the
selfish ledger no and i
don't even remember it by that name so
apologies the novovax vixen seems to use
a more traditional mechanism
would you feel safer taking novofax once
approved pending good trial data versus
mrna
i don't do you know what no ofx uses um
i have been
i have been saying you know i wish there
was a traditional vaccine available
um and i'm not finding it immediately
with a quick
uh duckduckgo search um
so that's probably not the place to do
it but
um uh you're a year in the making well
of course
of course it's a year in the making
that's not surprising um
using moth cells spike proteins
yeah i can't tell quickly um so
if it was traditional if it was an
actually traditional
uh form um yes i would be more excited
about taking it
i don't think that any traditional
vaccine has been developed in this
amount of time i think that would be
that would be i think it's like three
years might might be something like the
the record for a traditionally
uh traditional vaccine development
as it is you know as we've said many
times the dna vaccines
um like j which is available in the u.s
now
which have one rather than two for the
mrna vaccines
um very novel pieces of technology that
they're employing
is also being equal likely to be safer
just because there's
less totally new stuff that we don't
have experience historical experience
with
um but neither of us know enough about
the no facts vaccine to answer that
question particularly
i am not jealous of bret's hair the next
person says i
am jealous of eric's hair i save all my
alopecia ire for him
really i know okay okay sure that's it
you got that okay
if george bridges resigned oh he's he's
leaving
he's getting a sweet deal too but if
george bridges resigned and you were put
in charge of fixing evergreen
what steps would you take to curb the
problems with our woke educational
system
uh this is a longer topic yep
the fact is it's probably too late for
evergreen um maybe not but
they've doubled down so many times
that's gonna be very hard for them to
rescue
their reputation with evergreen you'd
have to be allowed to clean house
yeah both staff and faculty yeah but
then i think
i think it could be done yeah but the
fact is any college that could figure
out how to
go back to educating and uh resist
the woke revolution would have a massive
advantage so really the answer is can
you figure out how to get the mechanisms
that want to enforce uh diversity equity
and inclusion
fictions onto higher ed can you just
fend that off if you can fend that off
then
you imagine that you were the only
college in the country that managed to
fend it off of course everyone's going
to want to send their kids
there because that's where you'll get
educated so
in some ways it's an easy puzzle
logically speaking
but obviously those mechanisms are
industrial strength or
they wouldn't be universal yeah so a
conversation
many conversations for longer for later
but that's a good
good first step uh just thank you
[Music]
thank you for the gratitude
it's not it's not that there was no new
world megafauna but hypothesis they were
driven to extinction by human hunting
old world megaphonic co-evolved with
humans and no survived
and so survived to be domesticated
um so i think this is in response to the
gun's terms and steel
argument that i think there is a
misunderstanding of what you had
described as this hypothesis which is
that there wasn't any
um any what you had said was there
wasn't anything domesticable
in the new world and that is true it is
also true
and so and and diamond says the lack of
domesticable
uh megafauna in particular is about
basically you know
at its far too simple level
whether or not the continent is
arraigned a rage arranged sort of like
along a line of latitude or along
several lines of latitude such that
um the range in which you can take a
once domesticated animal
can can travel but it is certainly true
that there was a ton of megafauna in the
new world
and that um largely it went extinct
probably um around you know some some
combination
of sudden extreme hunting pressure and
um climate yeah um
i will say diamond's model i think which
is partially borrowed from other people
for why the animals aren't domesticable
involves
multiple different things um it'd be
worth going into
in greater depth but for example the
fact that um
horses have been domesticated but zebras
which would be
equally useful have never been
domesticated equally
good one equally useful yes
is attributed to the fact that
horses have have the right temperament
whereas um
zebras don't on because of the risk of
predation that zebras experience they're
too flighty
um so anyway the point is there's
several characteristics you need in
order to be domesticable
uh elephants are very useful and have
been utilized but they're too
slow to reproduce so they are always
taken from the wild
rather than raised in captivity they've
got too many ideas too well then they
don't have too many ideas to be
put to human work yeah um
but anyway so the point is you you did
have humans
presumably hunting out you know and the
overhunting hypothesis is controversial
but i think it's almost certain to be
right
um as a result of the fact that the
animals yes in the new world because the
animals didn't know to be afraid of
people because they hadn't seen any
um and so you can still experience their
level of indifference to people in the
galapagos for
example where the animals strangely
don't move out of your way
tripping over relatively large animals
yeah um
but in any case that's the only thing
that's skittish in the galapagos
is the house cats which are um there's
an attempt ongoing
to exterminate them because they put the
bird eggs at risk
yeah so anyway the domestic ability
question is complex it's multiple
factors but
those animals that were those large
animals that were domesticated
uh successfully um were
heavily concentrated in asia and then
moved into europe
so i don't think it is the overhunting
that caused there not to be those
animals
uh where was i here we go
would it be viable to distribute the cat
droppings or hair balls at increasing
distances away from the house to lure
coyotes away
over time uh no i don't think so we're
basically connected via a green space to
a
many hundred acre park that they are you
know rotating among and they you know
this is just the longest they've stuck
here
um usually they would have moved on by
now and for some reason they're not but
i'm going to skip i'll come back to
these questions but there's another one
um try wolf urine for the coyote issues
i live in the forest and have tons of
coyote they were even coming out in the
day hunting my chickens and goats no
issues since refresh it a few times a
year
cool where where did we get it yeah i
was in there at the extent dinosaur
store
i don't think they're gonna have it but
where do we get it i don't know i would
tell us
email the mod please yeah or we can
google it or duckduckgoat as the case is
right you wear it sorry you know i was
in a shop looking for a coyote repellent
and
i couldn't find anybody to talk to and i
assumed it didn't exist
wolf urine seems really improbable
like how do you get enough wolf urine to
right they're liable to resist that i'm
guessing that the muscle them first and
squeeze them
right um oh wait that's the
herpetologist in me talking it's
probably different from mammals
i'm guessing that they've figured out
what components are
uh important constituents yeah it's like
vanillin version it's vanilla
vanillin is to vanilla as the wolf iron
you can buy to
right to scare coyotes is too actual but
either way if it works that's
that's a great suggestion thank you
because we are obviously suffering all
sorts of
downstream effects of this and it's not
good no actually it will solve the
problem two ways it'll drive the
coyotes away and it'll cause the cats
never to want to go outside
again that's right it'll probably it'll
baffle and enrage maddie though
yeah our dog will be she may never speak
to us again
right okay um
heather i love your voice and notice
that you get hoarse sometimes
i suffer from the same problem any tips
on how to manage this with your
experience as a teacher and public
speaker
i don't i have actually heard from a
couple of people saying
find a good speech therapist there are
exercises
i tried to address this for years and
just had terrible doctors who said take
our drugs and then take our drugs for
the
things that these drugs will cause and i
never did and they said if you don't
take our drugs
we can't help you i said why do you
think i'm getting hoarse we don't know
but we think the drugs might help
so i am drinking today however um
this gosh this thing is life right and
um i used to get actual laryngitis like
twice a year and i don't get actual
total laryngitis anymore but i do get
hoarse a fair bit and this
this life elixir is um
super hot water with a over full
tablespoon or more depending on what you
like of real honey
and the juice of the juice of an entire
fairly large lemon
and uh it's just amazing it is amazing
it tastes great and you're sick it's
really good too oh man um yeah i will
say
i think there may be nothing to be done
for those of us who have
these kinds of issues including uh
apneas or whatever but i think a lot of
it is being caused by
deformations of the laryngeal apparatus
um
that are the result of radical changes
in diet check out
mike mew um but there's a lot to be said
he talks about hoarseness as well
no but i'm because i mean apnea sleep
jaw stuff like i've heard that but i've
never heard anything about um
the soft tissue around the lyrics and i
don't know why it wouldn't and i
actually well he does talk about the
soft tissue around the larynx he has not
as far as i know talked about hoarseness
in particular but my sense is that
there's just an awful lot of pathology
in this one neighborhood an
awful lot of mystery you know why are
people so prone to snoring
right it's like something novel has
happened
yeah yeah but i mean that is it feels
i feel like that's related but it feels
different also like you you're bringing
up apneas and here we're talking about
like it's it's it's a somewhat different
space
um i will say um if people
if anyone in portland is watching who
knows of actual uh
voice therapists that they um that they
think are actually skilled and qualified
i would be very interested to know
to know that um because i did i did
engage actually in a dialogue with um
someone who really knows what they're
talking about but they're in europe
um who said that they could you know
they could probably help
uh with what they hear as sort of
fatigue very quickly and
like that's great but i don't i don't
trust anyone here
um because i haven't i haven't yet found
anyone relevant
okay um follow up from last week
eg of virus host mutualism supposedly
it is it is suggested that parasitoid
wasps
inject poly dna virus into prey
to suppress their immunity so their eggs
won't be attacked
are there other such examples
i'm trying to understand what's being
suggested here
so we had a question last week about
poly dna virus and didn't know what they
were talking about and
um this person probably the same person
it suggested that parasite wasps inject
poly dna virus which is
a word that i've never heard before into
prey to suppress their immunity so their
eggs won't be attacked the idea is
parasitoid wasps
as you know um basically immobilize
prey like like tarantulas
and lay their eggs inside of it and then
as their eggs hatch they basically eat
their way out and the prey
obviously dies at some point but it
doesn't die
um until it starts being eaten from the
inside out thus
basically preserving a living meal for
the eggs when they do hatch the eggs of
the wasp
yeah and i've never heard this
hypothesis
so i want to know whether or not this is
actually a true
virus they separately evolved from the
wasp or is the wasp injecting something
that is having a effect on the uh
the prey item yeah anyway yeah
interesting we will look into it very
cool
um and then are there other such
examples i don't know of any yeah
yeah i didn't know of this one so i
don't i don't know of any
uh try wolf urine thank you yes um if
evolution is
try wolf urine
great okay we're doing it we
urine from amazon where there are no
wolves
they're bush dogs yes i wonder if bush
dog urine would work
probably not
if evolution is drivel but a drivel
[Laughter]
we may be about done if evolution is
driven
by survival of the fittest would you say
it's not surprising that capitalism is
uh
s of tf for the market
sfdf um is there any other
is there another evolutionary mechanic
it means mechanism
here i assume that would work on markets
so evolution is i'm sure i would know
what to make of this i just in the
context i'm not being able to fill in
the acronym here
if evolution is driven by survival of
the fittest would you say it's not
surprising that capitalism
is sotf uh
for the market is there another
evolutionary mechanism that would work
on markets
um uh it will occur to me what this
question means
in about an hour and a half i imagine i
don't know what it means
sorry um okay we got to get to one or
two that we can
actually answer well before we stop here
um
oh here's a link to the antibody testing
is not recommended to assess
immunity thing from the cdc thank you
for that um
this first part of this question is in
quotes and i don't know who is being
quoted and then it
has a question tin soldiers and nixon's
coming we're finally on our own
this summer i hear the drumming for dead
in ohio
yeah it's a lyric from a
crosby stills nash and young song okay
um how do you predict a biden presidency
will handle massive
scale rioting oh
boy i mean i'm i'm
i'm not sure there's any reason to
predict other
than um
virtue signaling ineffective response
uh a
um sensitivity to what the claimed
motive for a riot is rather than
enforcing the law
right that's what i'd predict
okay one last question i'm just going to
jump to the bottom because it's a good
one
good one to finish on i think and we'll
pick up one or two more of these next
week
um what is your take on woke cdc
calling racism a public health threat
will this
destroy the cdc's already fragile
credibility so they just they just did
this i mean
it's it's akin to what all those public
health officials
signed that letter at the beginning of
last summer shortly after the
after george floyd's death um
but the cdc is taking this moment um
to declare racism a public health threat
yes it will destroy comments what little
credibility they
have i feel like that's certain
anything more i don't know what else
there is to say i mean
obviously racism is bad it is being
diagnosed
um rather universally even where there's
no evidence for it it's not surprising
to see
government agencies piling on and you
know yes it's
it's basically what happened to the aclu
will happen to the cdc
and uh we will end up having to reinvent
these things
yeah maybe that's the place um to go
is that we needed the aclu and now we
don't have it
and we need the cdc and uh
it's not clear to what degree we we have
it i
have hope yet that it is not lost
because i really don't know how
how that gets rebuilt yeah especially at
a moment like this
you play games with these things is
insane yeah and that's what it is
um they're playing games as if they
don't understand what the actual risks
are
yep um which which yes that does destroy
their fragile credibility
legitimately because if they don't
actually know the risks of the games
that they are now playing then
um what do they know yep yeah
all right um i think that takes us about
to the end
of this week wow right
so um we'll be back in a week
uh for episode 76 with the requisite
number of trombones
um all right yeah is that right yes
trombones uh trombones and um
yeah please consider joining us on our
patreon subscribe to this channel
uh subscribe to the clip's channel if if
you like hopefully there's a lot more
frequent uh videos there
uh like um download the
audio app too with the audio app the uh
the podcast on
uh on audio that helps as well
and um be good to each other
be well see you next week
[Music]